today's topic uh i am not
passionate about youtube what about you
are you passionate about youtube
passionate that's a strong ass word no
i'm not passionate
about youtube it's great it's wonderful
i
i like what it it's brought me but
passionate um
no i keep my mind doing different things
just so i could do so i can't
no i can't be passionate about about
that what are you passionate about in
life if you have to pick like one or two
things just examples
um engines i'm a little nerd about that
motorcycle world dancing and even
what what is the difference between your
approach to those things and youtube
specifically
youtube is my job i was gonna say that
it's a job that i do that's that's what
it is that's that's that's where i get
my paper from
i like it and i enjoy a lot more aspects
than i had in previous jobs
don't incur but it's a job being
passionate about it
being passionate about it would be like
passion it would be like every time
something
someone says something about me which
happens a whole lot i'd be passionate
about it and
like i'd be pat i don't read all
all the comments like i read the
comments the mid like when the video is
out
then i read it at the same time i listen
to the video but other than that
i'm not passionate about it i i
understand
the woodwork and what it takes for me
like what it takes for me to go do my
job
but when i clock out i clock out
people right now we're about to reach a
million okay subscribers
it's the people that tell me yo you're
about to reach it yes
i'm not like blase i'm not man
it's just cool yeah we work towards that
goal that's the goal
on to the next goal it's part and parcel
why i think like the outro
still says 63k subscribers just to
remind you
yeah because how we were at 63k is how
we are now yes
i don't think it should change either
yeah 63k it says 63k
leave it at 63. yeah if i can find one
that
one that says 25k i put that
just to remind you you know
i think the reason why i say i'm not
passionate about it like if i compare it
to like stand up or dance i feel like in
order to be passionate about something
you have to suffer
and you don't allow yourself to suffer
not with youtube no because
the minute you don't want to do it you
don't stop except but dancing watching
yourself like watching you watching
yourself
not being good at the video and trying
to improve that yeah you just that
that's
like you want to do passion of course we
want to enjoy and
improve the product but we don't take
every offer to make money yeah
more importantly it's like when i when i
think about stand up and stuff like that
i enjoy the process of challenging
myself to be extremely uncomfortable
to do all kinds of i think with youtube
there's definitely we've come we've
settled into a very comfortable
you know pocket yes sir we have our our
system
we're good with it we have fun with it
you know what i mean it's just mean you
talking
yes sir you know what i'm saying but i
don't think we challenge ourselves on
youtube
with
there's more passion in running the
open mic that we have yeah than running
this
i'm not saying that there's not more
work or whatever what not it's just that
yo the way we came at each other like
okay no this bit is not funny b
it's not this and trying to work it then
no we cannot you're not
we cannot put that person because it's
going to mess up this show
i'm passionate about that yeah you know
i think it is also it's because it's
hard to be passionate about something
that feels so impersonal
in a weird way yeah when i when i do
stand up i can go from like doing a
thousand people show
and people are applaud and go wild then
next i go to open mic i bomb
and i just can't wait for the next
process and writing and improving on the
set right
when i do this i drop the jokes and it's
just numbers and i know it's real people
and i know it means a lot for you guys
so some of you guys messages in them and
i'm happy
angry that it helps you but when it
comes to the actual work itself it's
hard for me to like get a huge amount of
emotional satisfaction
or any kind of like sense of achievement
part of that is
the way the environment is shaped the
numbers and it's just
the red arrow when when you're doing
worse this month and the green arrow
when you're doing better and
it's all these random numbers you can't
really always understand
but another part is our approach we
don't approach it
from a place of passion or an artistic
way we don't
approach it from like how can we be
really creative we're just like we'll
just fill this in and
just chit chat and that's it you know
you see two people grabbing a coffee
and they talking that's what it feels
like but it's like we're facing the
camera and there's a light behind it
you know what i'm saying yeah so that's
one of those weird things that i had to
acknowledge recently
because i saw everyone else's excitement
over the youtube channel people like why
aren't you excited i'm like
i think it's cool and don't get me wrong
i'm grateful because again at the end of
the day it still supports the people
around me
but one thing i have to acknowledge is
like when i do youtube i don't try to be
super creative i don't
try to do and that's not necessarily a
bad thing for a lot of you you guys just
come here for the regular dose and it's
enough and i'm
happy to offer you but i also recognize
that's part of the reason why
we won't necessarily reach that top
echelon no we're not reaching or we're
trying
which good or bad maybe we're taking it
for granted there's a lot of different
perspectives to come out of it
i haven't reached it so i don't know
yeah i don't know i don't know what it's
like can we reach it with doing people
on doing what we're doing
i don't know yeah i just i know what it
takes for me to come here and to
generate laughs
i know how to do this thing can we we'll
see but it's it's a it's a job
that's why i like whenever i stop
clowning um
youtubers and influencers it's a job
yeah
it is a job but you have to invest
yourself but yeah a passion
oh no no yeah
people's life so when you used to dance
oh i still dance yeah no i have to dance
so when you used to dj i still
i can't stop that so when you used to do
comedy no it's not because you don't see
it that i don't
do it that i would be yeah i would i
would say that that that's that would be
but there's a joy there
there's like um there's a struggle there
with youtube i just don't feel struggle
i feel
no resistance and i feel like i'm not
putting anything in front of me to make
resistance
i'm just chilling stand up it's like
there's those ups and downs
within a set i'll get more excitement
from a stand-up set
you know with the dead dead moments and
then the high laughters then i will from
this yeah because there's no real
uncertainty with this
i mean yeah there is i mean we could
stop they could we could stop we could
we could well self-imposed yes
or even even on the platform the
platform we don't know what can happen
with that or whatever whatnot but then
again that's why i do other projects
like that i try to i try to diversify
but i try to diversify just because i
need a challenge as well
yeah but that's not the same as
uncertainty within a craft like yeah of
course
you know the whole industry could
collapse at any second of course but my
point being is like
it's not the same as the first person
feel you get when you're dancing
and you're going through a song and a
breakdown happens or when you're really
in a like a in
a movement pattern or whatever it's just
different it's just different i agree
yeah and i guess it's just weird for
folks who don't understand we're like
what do you mean you're not excited
about i don't know i just i've never
never been like that with youtube
i just do whatever maybe it's just just
the fact that i like the meanings of
words
you know i and and excited is not the
right word
passionate it's just not the right word
i like what i do i enjoy what i do
i'm happy humbled i'm i'm grateful for
what i'm doing
that i'm in that position i've been able
to have that but passionate is a strong
strong word
it is but we do have that in our life we
have passion for certain crafts so i was
just
always thinking like why not for this
you take the fun because it's a job you
take the funniest video
that i that i think of adam and preach i
got two of my top twos
all right i watched them and it does not
it's funny i'm gonna laugh
but it does not equate the joy of the
feeling of let's say
when i'm on a dance floor and i hear it
gets to me yeah anyway
and then there's a song that pops up
there's it does not equate that
but whenever like i'm next to my friend
dj and
he asked me to just drop a track yeah
and i dropped the track and
people go wow because it's a track you
know because there's nothing better than
not
not hearing the song that you wanted to
hear but hearing the song that you
didn't know you wanted to hear yeah
it doesn't equate to having a stand-up
ovation from
stand-up comedy or just having a room
that it no it doesn't it doesn't right
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point it's interesting it doesn't mean
i'm not putting down the youtube game
though you know i'm just saying it's
just two different things
no so those are our thoughts on the
matter that would just be cool to have a
conversation about that
but what do you guys think
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]